eines meiner letzten videos war
inspiriert von diesem präparat mit
quadratischen reifen ich dachte mir was
wäre wenn man dieses prinzip einfach auf
andere sachen anwendet um zum beispiel
den gründen billardtisch baut während
ich aber daran gearbeitet habe und
ausschnitte aus dem fahrrad video mit
dem besagten kann er zeigen wollte um
euch meine inspiration zu erklären ist
mir aufgefallen dass es zwar dutzende
videos gibt mit diesem tag aber es im
gesamten internet kein einziges video
gibt's das auch tatsächlich ein normales
fahrrad mit eckigen rädern zeigt noch
nicht mal die künstliche intelligenz
dalí tut die wirklich jeden erdenklichen
nonsens in form eines komplett neu
generierten bildes super realistisch aus
dem nichts zaubern kann war in der lage
ein viereckiges fahrrad vorzustellen
jesus der eine raucht während er auf dem
fahrrad über das wasser fährt als
verdammtes glas musik das war für die ki
kein problem aber vierecke die reifen
sind einfach zu krass auf youtube habe
ich diese videos hier gefunden die zwar
relativ spannend sind aber kaum schon
die räder sind aus holz und die fahrbahn
ist speziell dafür designt wir alle da
bin ich mir sicher wollen aber sehen wie
ein richtiges echtes fahrrad mit echten
luftgefüllten viereckigen greifen über
eine richtige straße fährt aber noch
nicht mal ein echtes foto gibt es davon
nur wenige illustrationen und
fotomontagen und original genau nur ein
foto oder sie malen 1948 wirklich
durchgezogen hat verdammt der legende
also wäre er wenn er wenigstens mal wie
weit ich gehabt hätte für drei sekunden
sein iphone aus der tasche zu holen um
wieder zu machen das zeigt wie es
aussieht wenn das teil fährt was für ein
anfänger also machen wir das jetzt
dieses video wird unterstützt von annie
finden mehr dazu später was suchst du
einen fahrer hallo wächst also so ein
teil der im hinteren räder wird schon
das ist ja ein problem wie wollen wir
denn die bremse machen
das heißt wir lassen uns also bleiben
sie weg ja wir brauchen hin
ich will kaufe meinen braucht
mountainbike es ist fahrbereit kann vor
ort getestet werden dann schauen wir
noch mal nachrichten ich weiß haben wir
jeden tag an
haben wir euch nachricht dass hier
liegen
ich habe jetzt eben die gleiche name
geschrieben ich habe den namen angepasst
habe vergessen mit dem preis anzupassen
ich meinte natürlich
80 eur
selbst
unangenehm
letzte servus markus
wir kruse also durch den süden
deutschland und haben zwei treffen
vereinbaren eines der räder hatte
einfach einen platten also haben wir
natürlich nicht kauft der käufer den wir
selbst nicht angetroffen haben weil
deine freundin vor geschickt hat hat mir
das mit dem platzen aber warum auch
immer nicht so ganz geglaubt danke dafür
ebay kleinanzeigen fündig sind wir dann
aber trotzdem geworden
tesco
so tatsächlich hat ein ganzes fahrrad
angepasst hätte ich nicht gedacht den
kollegen noch mal gleichviel
so da ist es wirklich keinen plan von
fahrrädern also ich hab wirklich keine
ahnung wie sie auch richtig rum ist kann
man das über forschung die breakchancen
sind weg dagegen trägt
[Musik]
gott hat vorgemacht wie gesagt ich habe
überhaupt kein plan fahrer dann
allerdings ob wir überhaupt modifiziert
da ist glaube ich nichts mehr original
sieht so aus als hätte jemand mal
richtig richtig viel reingesteckt
[Musik]
so waren wir erst mal kaputt macht dafür
die da war das bordell wieder ab einmal
so ich stelle jetzt an es ist die
speichen herauskriegt weil ich braucht
das teil youtube weißt du schon weiter
sie meint ich musste für den man glaubt
man heute noch nie was mit dem fahrrad
gemacht sollte ein luft rausnehmen
erstmal oder wie mache ich das muss ich
nicht aufdrehen zuerst machen sondern
einfach dass er jetzt aufdrehen
so wie oh das ist ja gar nicht geil
[Musik]
digger
jetzt ein schraubenzieher und das sollte
auch funktion ich glaube braucht man
keinen speziellen tool oder das gejammer
komplett locker wie sich aus wo es ist
ohne witz das gericht nicht so perfekt
so also eigentlich sollte ich jetzt hier
die dinger schon rausschrauben können
aber da sind wir so gut wie dazwischen
den hebel ich auch noch aus so und jetzt
kann hineingehen mit einem kreuz
schlitten ist richtig mal ab jetzt erst
draußen den kollegen jetzt sollte ich
theoretischen speichern irgendwie
rauswählen
einmal mehr machten hier schlitz
schrauben rein
ich so macht man denn überhaupt schnitts
schrauben
[Musik]
jetzt muss ich die denken ja die
rausfliegen
so sieht also ein zerlegter
fahrradreifen haus hätte ich auch nicht
gedacht soll für den rest entscheiden
die bremse der knochen oder
schiesser sind fest
[Musik]
jetzt aber
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist also das erste bauteil den
anfang und nachdem ich das alles ohne
extra werkzeug gemacht attestierte
scheinlich ein spezialwerkzeug gebäude
ich glaube der paketbote denkt ich habe
ein problem wahrscheinlich kennt ihr das
ja auch wenn ihr was online bestellt was
super teuer ist und vielleicht habt ihr
ja wie viele andere dann ratenkauf
ausgewählt was viele aber nicht wissen
ratenkauf bedeutet immer dass man den
kredit abschließt und das war oft mit zu
hohen zinsen von teilweise über zehn
prozent lief in der ist bei unseres
heutigen videos kann euch dabei helfen
herauszufinden ob ihr vielleicht auch zu
hohe zinsen bezahlt ihr müsst dafür nur
die android app über den link in der
video beschreibung herunterladen und
dort die infos zu eurem ausstehenden
ratenkredit eingeben
und falls einige von euch ein besseres
angebot mit niedrigeren zinsen machen
kann er hatte das direkt über die app
wenn ihr übrigens am 13 gehalt
weihnachtsgeld oder eine gehaltszahlung
bekommen könnte auch jederzeit kostenlos
die ratenhöhe nach oben anpassen oder
sonderzahlungen tätigen damit er den
kredit so schnell wie möglich los solche
anpassungen könnt ihr ganz easy über den
chat auf der website oder in der app
erledigen also ladet euch jetzt endlich
bin runter und mit dem coach terry
bekommt er sogar noch 20 euro abzukaufen
kredit
so jetzt habe ich alle teile einmal und
ursprung in meinem planen dass teile
jetzt aber wirklich zu biegen aber keine
chance bricht dann einfach deswegen
müssen wir diese felge einmal komplett
neu bauen unser direkt in viereckig und
da hab ich mal alles und gern pc hier
zeichne ich erst die maße der
langweiligen runden felgen ein und
wandelt diese dann in aufregende
rechteckige um bestehend aus alu
profilen anders als bei runden reifen
haben die löcher für die felgen auch
nicht den gleichen abstand weswegen ich
hier erst die radnabe nach konstruiere
und dann ausgehend von der mitte 32
löcher in die alu profile projiziert
so jetzt wäre die erste frage an sich
schon fertig sein jetzt haben natürlich
das problem dass nicht alle sprechen
gleich lang sind deswegen müssen wir die
guten dinge hier noch ein bisschen zu
schneiden jetzt kann ich leider nicht
einfach die distanz von dem loch zu dem
dort messen und dann hatte ich auf die
länge schneiden ganz einfach weil die
speichen mal so ein fahrrad echt crazy
angeordnet sind
[Musik]
sie sprechen wir zum beispiel die sich
hintenrum eingefädelt werden die
speicher hier vorne rum eingefädelt ist
und die beiden gehen jetzt ungefähr
parallel hier nach oben und zwar genau
ein loch auseinander das heißt ich muss
jetzt zb distanz von dem loch zu
dem auch gemessen und habe dann quasi
hier mit diesen beiden mein erstes
speichen war ich mag ihr also wo die
speichen hinkommen produzieren wir dann
die längen auf die ich die speichen
später zu schneiden muss anschließend
trug ich die zeichnung aus schreibt noch
ein paar anmerkungen dazu und legt sie
auf - werkbank der dann die alu profile
zuschneidet und bohrt die später die
felge bilden werden
[Musik]
so jetzt gesagt schweißen meine
lieblingsdisziplin die ich tatsächlich
aber nicht weg kann irgendwie muss ich
das zeug festhalten will ich mal
behaupten er ist es schon mal richtig
schön angespannt jetzt mal allerdings
zuvor und zwar erstens überhaupt
funktioniert ich habe auch niemanden
leben aluminium gespeist es sind jetzt
hier spezielle alle elektroden und
verschweißt mir sind zwei abwehr stücke
der stadtteile mal grantig statt 120 mph
bisschen mehr noch einmal gerät 40
ich weiß jetzt nicht so krass
wie jetzt dann sagen wir
legen jetzt eher schlecht als recht also
ich weiß nicht so geil
der perfekt das war jetzt überhaupt
nicht stabil also eine schöne schweiz
nachträglich aluminium und dem relativ
günstigen scheiße hier auf jeden fall
nicht hin aber er auch nicht wenig
stabil
also man kann es kaputt machen was ich
nicht 100 prozent optimal ist also muss
man hinterher noch mal verstärken aber
ich mache jetzt mal ran ans richtige
rand
[Musik]
die allererste fähige ist wer dich also
ist jetzt nicht wunderschön aber es
funktioniert ich überlegen ob ich hier
im abschluss allerdings glaube ich nicht
ja doch ich glaube hier muss man sagen
abschleifen
[Musik]
muss passen meint man die narbe rein und
fangen damit an die allererste speicher
wird es ein bisschen kompliziert weil
ich hier noch zu schneiden muss auch die
richtige länge ich fange mal an mit
20,8 cm
dann bin ich das um quasi wieder das
teil hier zu kriegen
das kommt quasi allein
der komplizierten ich mache direkt mal
fest und jetzt hält das erste speichert
manchmal gehen wir die zweite reden das
ja auch durch
und jetzt wünschen wir ersten zwei
speichern damit verbunden fehlen nur
noch ungefähr 50
[Musik]
jetzt alle dran aber
nicht gespannt weil seine welt
singles ganzen verzogen
[Musik]
das ist die erste tägliche verträge in
dem video sieht auf jeden fall so aus
als sei es verboten sein
nachdem die vordere felge fertig ist
fehlt natürlich noch die hinter der
größte unterschied zur vorderen berge
ist hier dass wir dafür erst mal den
ketten cantz abmontieren müssen wofür es
eigentlich spezialwerkzeug gibt aber da
wir das nicht haben improvisieren wir
eben und anders als erwartet
funktioniert das sogar
[Musik]
es ist extrem geil ich bin es mich k
nein wie man damit fahren kann das sehen
wir natürlich erst später aber ich bin
es mir ja gar nicht hätte schon mal ob
es nicht aushält oder die hexen bricht
so ich sitze drauf wir ein bisschen rum
aber
das bringt wenig zusammen sehr geil so
wurde es allerdings wirklich natürlich
fahren kann hoffentlich fehlen hier noch
die mäntel unbedingt schlau und sagen
muss ich aus dem grunde mantel den
geraden machen und das ist ein bisschen
schwierig weil natürlich der so design
ist dass er hier einfach halt und ist
deswegen hab ich die idee dass ich das
hier unten jetzt mal ab knips
und ich denen dann jetzt ein bisschen
gerade machen kann hier und das tut sie
dann auch gleich gut
[Musik]
so das ist schon mal relativ gerade bin
ich gut und sie stellen die ich
aufgeschnitten haben werden jetzt wieder
zusammengenäht weil der mantel sonst
nicht anständig im alu profile halten
würde
[Musik]
das haben wir hier ein 4 gang fahrrad
nannte megageil s4 fahrradschlauch drin
und das ist eine wichtige
herausforderung da hab ich nämlich keine
ahnung
ich nehme mal ein
macht aber so ein bisschen luft rein
sehr gut dann kommt er mal wieder raus
jetzt ist mir folgendes aufgefallen zwei
personen schlafen meint ihr ist ja
logisch und das muss natürlich jetzt
auch irgendwie dadurch drohen muss ich
das geht aus meisten hier nochmal noch
reinmachen hier haben wir acht
millimeter dann nämlich klarerweise
einmal 8,5 mit dass auf jeden fall
leicht durchgeht
[Musik]
wir wohnen gestern perfekt durch habe
genau aussehen werde ich schlafe ich
hier verbraucht und normalerweise sollte
das 22 zoll aus sein ob diese
berechnungen aber stimmen ja das wäre
jetzt ausgebucht so
ok das sollte hinhauen ich hoffe einfach
mal dass das teils nicht kaputt geht
dann irgendwie was ich jetzt der mantel
hier noch zwischen
schlauch und fähige
ich kann es kaum glauben als
geil
ist das geil man kann es einfach
aufpumpen also es geht halt leider noch
ein bisschen art hier zum beispiel und
warum ist so wichtig ist dass der mantel
an der felge gehalten wird hat manu
unbeabsichtigt ganz demonstriert
[Musik]
also an irgendwelchen ismus dafür sorgt
dass der mantel auch drinnen gehalten
wird wenn man es auch punkt und ich habe
auch schon eine idee wie das
funktioniert und zwar wird ein fahrrad
mantel normal mit einer art wurst in der
felge gehalten wenn sich der schlauch
aussehen als improvisierte nachbildung
mache ich jetzt pro seite drei löcher
samt gewinde und schraubt dann eine
maden schrauberei wir den mantel davon
abhalten soll heraus zu rutschen und
wenn man jetzt auf pump
schon besser
[Musik]
so also ungefähr eine woche arbeit für
uns jetzt genau hierhin
dieses
also theoretisch kann man auch immer
kurven fahren
sieht dann so aus wenn man den schiebt
auf jeden fall hin gerade eben bin ich
ja bisher abgefahren das ging ja so
ungefähr und jetzt falsch mit leichter
steigung ihr euch war
und so haben wir unsere mission erfüllt
das erste video von einem fahrenden 4
gegen fahrrad zu erschaffen wir haben
das unmögliche möglich gemacht und das
unbrauchbare
noch unbrauchbar vielen dank auch mal
ein handy findet dieses video möglich
gemacht haben genauso wie sie möglich
machen dass ihr eure kredite loswerden
über den link in der beschreibung ich
bin damit raus macht's gut